pour assurer la conservation d'une
espèce il faut savoir où elle se trouve
sur le territoire et connaître la
tendance de sa population est ce qu
elles se raréfient ce qu'elle est stable
pour répondre à ces questions un groupe
de chercheurs et d'ornithologues pour la
plupart amateurs ont effectué un travail
colossal qui permet aujourd'hui de
savoir comment se portent les oiseaux
nicheurs du québec
[Musique]
ces oiseaux nous sont familiers on les
voit autour de nos maisons en ville dans
les champs et dans les forêts
[Musique]
alors que certains vont bien d'autres
sont en déclin si on peut faire
aujourd'hui ce constat c'est grâce à cet
ouvrage de référence incomparable le
deuxième atlas des oiseaux nicheurs du
québec méridional
pour réaliser ce travail souvent dans de
rudes conditions
il a fallu compter sur quelque 2
millions mythologue pour la plupart
bénévoles
leurs efforts ont permis de répertorier
253 espèces d'oiseaux qui nichent et se
reproduisent dans le sud du québec
durant cinq ans de 2010 à 2014
ces bénévoles ont parcouru plus de 4000
parcelle de 10 kilomètres carrés antoine
baehni le permis ou encore gérard cyr et
jean michel lagueux tremblay ont
participé à l'effort collectif pour
réaliser cet atlas dernière n'est pas
loin d'ici
des sorties comme celle ci ils en ont
fait des centaines père des carreaux à
la recherche d'un indice visuel et
sonore de nidification
[Musique]
forcément ça va aller voir ce que j'ai
fait j'ai intégré le patient dans un
projet qui était super comme la table
ronde initiale du québec
pour bien leur ouvrir la queue qui n'est
pas ce livre on a fait ça pendant cinq
ans tout ce qu'on voyait qu'on observait
on notait sur pour les besoins de
l'atlas puis un coq comme ça où est-ce
qu'un oiseau sony c'est un des critères
ou un des indices idéal pour confirmer
la présence de l'oiseau la présence la
nidification des oiseaux ce territoire
comme qualité ça prend énormément de
traction parce que les oiseaux sont très
très très discret un bon sens de
l'observation faut détecter le moindre
petit mouvement le dans les broussailles
par terre dans le siège soit habitude de
regarder leur vraiment 360 degrés autour
de nous mais moi je trouve sur
extraordinaire je pense que l'atlas est
un bon exemple de ce que l'union peut
faire la force
michel robert et biologiste au service
canadien de la faune
c'est lui qui a coordonné les travaux de
l'atlas ski magnifique ce que on réalise
que quand les gens veulent faire quelque
chose en commun ils peuvent y arriver
pendant que de l'atlas un très bel
exemple c'est une très belle réussite
est ce qu'on aurait pu le faire sans son
nom je crois pas en 1995 un premier
atlas des oiseaux nicheurs du québec
méridional voit le jour
à cette époque on répertorie 200 43
espèces d'oiseaux sur le territoire
c'est 10 de moins que dans le plus
récent relevé
avec le deuxième atlas il est possible
de voir la répartition est aussi
l'abondance des oiseaux et surtout de
faire des comparaisons
il ya eu du positif du négatif des
espèces qui étaient extrêmement avoir il
ya 25 ans voire absente qui sont
toujours aujourd'hui à ces communes dans
québec méridional eux mêmes des espèces
qui sont pratiquement disparu du québec
méridional en l'espace de 25 ans donc
étonnamment même sur le laps de temps
est ainsi qu il ya eu beaucoup de
changements
pour certaines espèces d'oiseaux
le déclin est phénoménal et c'est en
campagne qu'on se rend compte qu'il y
avait ritable problème quand ce résultat
de la tâche qui vous fait que les
oiseaux sont de bons indicateurs de
l'état de l'environnement
on est à même de constater que
les choses ont beaucoup changé depuis 25
ans en terme d'habitants dans le québec
méridional
parmi les grands perdants on retrouve
des insectivores aériennes ces oiseaux
qui se nourrissent d'insectes en plein
vol mais les essais que tu variés c'est
un des constats de l'atlas la situation
votre aimable de façon générale à peu
près tout les hirondelles sont dans une
situation préoccupante la même chose
pour le martinet ramoneur par exemple
l'hirondelle rustique qui nichent ici en
arrière au but ces populations baissé de
75% entre la fin du premier atlas et le
deuxième à trans donc en 90 et 2014 qui
est quand même assez préoccupant
[Musique]
il est temps l'or a participé comme
bénévole à la préparation de la classe
dans la région de portneuf
il était aux premières loges pour voir
les quatorze aussi chez les oiseaux
champêtre qui eux niche dans les champs
on a là des endroits où est ce qu'avait
dit journal des prix d'une année à
l'autre son focus et la localiser il y
en a moins
faut faire plus de route par l'est les
voir c'est vrai certaines espèces
d'oiseaux champêtre ont presque disparu
du paysage agricole et zouzou champêtre
ne vont pas bien qui fait pas du tout
l'effectif de leur population est en
déclin
un certain quota sont majeurs logique à
75 à 80% selon les espèces c'est le cas
de l'alouette et même de certains
oiseaux plus communs comme le pluvier
qu'il dira qui se fait aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus rares alors comment
expliquer ces changements majeurs
survenus depuis 25 ans
la cause principale c'est c'est sans
doute la transformation du paysage
agricole
maintenant les agriculteurs font ce
qu'on appelle de l'agriculture intensive
donc et souvent de la culture annuel
donc du maïs et du soya
je suis mis ensemble ça a fait en sorte
que l'environnement est beaucoup moins
propice à la nidification de certaines
espèces d'oiseaux
[Musique]
mais il n'ya pas que cela
usage des pesticides est maintenant
répandu des insecticides notamment donc
si au moins d'insectes
il ya moins d'insectes pour nourrir les
oiseaux mais il n'ya pas que des
perdants
certaines espèces d'oiseaux ont connu
des hausses spectaculaires depuis la
publication du premier acte l'accident
[Musique]
on voit vraiment si le l'expansion dans
sa cour arrière
l'ornithologue amateur pronal lepage
consulte le deuxième atlas des oiseaux
nicheurs en compagnie de la biologiste
marie-hélène h et du regroupement
québecoiseaux et la travailler comme
adjointe à la coordination de l'ouvragé
milieu urbain de nombreuses espèces ont
su s'adapter grâce à des amoureux
d'oiseaux comme monsieur lepage qui les
nourrit à l'année
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup de mangeoires ça leur
donne une source de nourriture qui est
très riche qui les aide aussi à passer à
travers du vatican le printemps arrive
ces oiseaux là sont plus nombreux donc
peuvent se reproduire de façon plus
importante donc continuer à progresser
c'est le cas du cardinal rouge dont la
population a été multipliée par blic
depuis 25 ans il réchauffement du climat
y est pour quelque chose
il faudrait que ces oiseaux là sont pas
des oiseaux migrateurs
c'est des oiseaux qui passent l'hiver
ici donc un hiver plus doux veut dire
qu'ils vont avoir un meilleur succès un
meilleur succès de survie donc une
meilleure survie hivernale
[Musique]
en plein coeur de québec marie hélène h
et observent depuis des années la
progression constante des rapaces
depuis l'interdiction du ddt dans les
années 70 un pesticide qui fragilise et
la coquille de leur zone les rapaces
vont vraiment nous
ce qu'on voit derrière nous c'est
l'hôtel delta il n'y a pas juste des
gens qui habitent le y aussi le faucon
pèlerin
les faucons pèlerins niche sur des
falaises donc ici ça ressemble à une
grosse falaise puis tout à leur tour il
ya beaucoup de nourriture pour eux il ya
des pigeons d'un port de québec qui ont
un peu partout alentour donc ça leur
fait inhabituel qui leur convient très
bien
montréal n'est pas en reste près d'une
dizaine de couples de faucons pèlerins
ont élu domicile sur des structures un
peu partout en ville
comme ce fut le cas ces dernières années
à l'échangeur turcot l'épervier de
cooper et le faucon et mérillon profite
aussi de ces conditions favorables tout
comme le pygargue à tête blanche qu'on
retrouve désormais presque partout au
québec
et puis il y aller petit nouveau venu
récemment du sud comme le des dents
sauvage et l'urubu à tête rouge que l'on
aperçoit de plus en plus oui
le double est trop chez un autre corps
le grand succès si on peut dire les
rubans tête rouge c'est un oiseau qui
était extrêmement rare au québec à
l'époque première attaque on a beaucoup
beaucoup à la sortie du port de québec
donc cet oiseau là en bénéficient aussi
de l'interdiction du ddt mais il ya
aussi un autre facteur qui jouait pour
lui c'est que l'explosion dès
populations de chevreuils dans le sud du
québec
ça fait en sorte que lui ce charognard
donc ça fait beaucoup plus de carcasse
pour mieux manger donc plus de bourses
plus de succès à votre docteur
[Musique]
ce deuxième atlas arrive à point
à l'heure où les fausses informations
sont omniprésentes
un ouvrage scientifique réalisée avec
rigueur devient d'autant plus pertinent
pour aider à prendre des décisions
éclairées
pour ce qui est des résultats c'est
assez extraordinaire de pouvoir en
l'espace de quelques années de
documenter des changements aussi
importants
je crois qu'on va répéter se projette
dans l'avenir puisque chouette
d'enfoncer clair les décideurs et les
gens qui qui ont pouvoir d'influencé
puisse se servir de ce type d'ouvragé
pour prendre conscience que des façons
de faire qui devront peut-être changer
non
[Musique]